[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your green oh I bet that you'll
be fine without me live from the
Danforth music hall my name is Joshua
fields Melbourne and I am Ryan Nicodemus
and together we are the minimalists live
in Toronto
[Applause]
okay okay okay
welcome to the minimalist podcast where
we discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less Toronto you
all are awesome thank you for being and
I we we're here to answer your questions
usually we take phone calls but we don't
want you to have to call us up right now
so there's a microphone I believe
somewhere right up here
if you want to form a line we'll answer
as many questions as we can in the time
allotted by the theater here and first
well while you all are lining up man I
tell you what we've we've been to Canada
a few times now and it just keeps keeps
on getting better
this place is amazing every time we come
yeah amen absolutely go ahead and give
us your name where you're from and what
your question is so you're welcome to
move the mic do whatever you need to do
is obviously decided to quit your jobs
and I was wondering what sparked that
like was it a process or whether is
there a defining moment for you what
were you thinking did you feel ready
yeah Danny quite well Josh suggested
that we quit our jobs and start a blog
so terrible plan yeah if anyone tells
you that head for the hills
so did anything spark it here's here's
the thing at first no I was rather
content with the job that I had in fact
I wouldn't even call it a job it was a
career I worked really hard and I was
really really good at what I did in fact
the first thing you do when you meet
someone often is what do you ask them
what do you do and I had an impressive
answer to that question I was a director
of operations 450 retail stores which is
really ironic with the whole minimalism
thing
and and so I was comfortable and that
was actually the problem I didn't love
what I did and it wasn't a terrible
company or an evil corporation or
anything like that it just didn't align
with my values I didn't know that at the
time because if I'm being honest with
you I didn't know what my values were I
probably would have if you would have
asked me I could have given you a good
off-the-cuff answer but it wouldn't have
been a line esses airily it just
wouldn't have been the truth I would
have told you my health as a priority
but at one point I weighed 80 pounds
more than I weigh right now I would have
told you that my relationships were a
priority but of course I was spending
all my time with networking buddies and
executives and colleagues and forsaking
the people closest to me because all of
my time was spent at work and and and
trying to climb that corporate ladder
and so I was comfortable enough but I
didn't feel that sense of fulfillment
from what I was doing not that now all
of a sudden everything is at in my manic
running around like crazy but my life
now aligns my daily actions with what my
long-term values are there was a moment
when I decided to leave though my boss
came to me two weeks before Christmas
this was 2010 so I'd already embraced
minimalism and it was a over a year
after my mother died my marriage ended
and I've been working really hard to pay
off a bunch of debt and and my balls
came in to me a couple weeks before
Christmas and he said all right after
the holiday shopping season we have to
close eight stores and we need to let go
42 employees and I said okay I've done
this before we had downsized right-sized
out sighs whatever they're calling it
these days and when when he came to me I
said that's okay he said you have two
weeks put together a plan so I went home
that night and I started putting
together the plan and I started putting
everyone's name on a spreadsheet with
their performance that's what the
numbers do the talking and the 42 bottom
performers had to go but then as I was
doing that I got hit by this sort of
wall of emotion I realized that looking
at that spreadsheet
with just the names these weren't just
names these were moms and dads and sons
and brothers and there were people with
careers they were going to be affected
their lives are going to be affected and
it was like looking at a rainbow in
black and white just looking at these
these names on the spreadsheet and so I
put together the plan in two days and
and my name was the first name on the
list and my boss didn't believe me at
first in fact he said the one of the
most terrifying things that's ever been
said to me I'm not going to let you quit
I was like oh [ __ ] he could do that but
after about a month of talking it
through with him he knew that my heart
wasn't in that anymore wasn't in line
with my values I wasn't trying to judge
them I was simply judging my own life
and I had to not just walk away from
that but I had that something to walk
toward as well and to me I always wanted
to write and writing fiction was the
initial plan in fact I was gonna write
fiction full time and there was a coffee
shop two blocks from my house that I was
gonna work at and then this whole
minimalism thing was a really beautiful
accident so thank you all for that
yeah yeah for me it was I mean there's
when I learned about minimalism because
when I was having a conversation with
Josh about simplicity and clearing the
clutter and making room for life's most
important things I was like oh yeah like
it was common sense to me like oh yeah
if I don't have this huge mortgage
hanging over my head if I don't have a
new car payment every every couple years
take on the new car payment if I could
get out of this credit card debt maybe I
wouldn't have to work 60 70 80 hours a
week to maintain this lifestyle and you
know I don't think there was like this
you know exact spark I think that's what
pushed me over the edge but leading up
to that first I want to say there's
nothing wrong with corporations there's
absolutely I think that they can be
problematic I think they're inherently
problematic just because money is the
bottom line and that puts people and
everything else after that but the
problem with where I worked is it didn't
align with my values and beliefs and it
was at a point where like I said in my
talk I was drinking like excessive
amounts every single day and if it
wasn't drinking then I was out doing
whatever drugs I could get my hands on
and the reason why I was doing that is
because it was like this pacifier this
quick fix to the anxiety that I was
feeling from work and then I remember
after you know a few promotions I'm I
was responsible for like business sale I
had a really nice answer to that
question - like what do you do like I I
manage a small medium home business
sales in 150 retail stores so my boss I
was in there for in his office for a
like a quarterly review maybe you like I
think it was like after the holiday
season and I remember when I first like
got my sales goals that before that
quarter before the holiday season I just
I called them up and I'm like dude this
is way like you're you're crazy like
there's no way we're gonna do this and
he was like you know gave me a little
pep talk and you know I know you can do
it you know whatever I was like okay I'm
like but if I hit if I hit this you got
to give us a break first quarter next
year so I'm in his office and I was so
happy because like I hit like 120
percent to goal which was awesome and he
gives him up he gives me my numbers
during our quarterly review and I'm like
the sales numbers for that following
quarter and they were like astronomical
again I'm like dude I'm like we did we
had this talk like four months ago that
if I hit this goal that you wouldn't put
pressure on like that this like my guys
need a break I can't work him 60 hours a
week for the rest of their lives and he
was like you know started reaming me
about how you're not close enough to
your people and you should have had 125
percent and then he points to this it
was like something his kindergarten his
his little boy from kindergarten had a
wrote and it was it was a picture of him
in like in like a skyscraper and then up
top it said my daddy works for and then
the company was there I'm just not gonna
call it out because I really don't wanna
bash the company I got nothing against
them um he he's a boss he's the boss of
this company
he's like no ideas that is like you know
senior VP of you know and he goes to say
like my dad works a lot he sometimes
doesn't come home for dinner sometimes I
fall asleep before he gets home like I'm
paraphrasing here because I can't
remember the exact words but it was
something along those lines and he's
like do you see what I give up for you
I'm like and like that moment I'm like
wow maybe one day I can have your job
it'd be just as miserable as you and and
I think that is what combined with
everything else that was kind of
snowballing up to that point I was just
looking for a way to get out and when I
came across minimalism that was that was
my way of simplifying my life
the ultimate goal was to get as much out
of debt as I could I was trying to get
debt-free before I left the corporate
world I ended up getting laid off a
little bit after that but luckily I had
prepared myself by simplifying as much
as possible but yeah that was my goal
too is I was gonna be a barista I mean
Josh and I talked about being baristas
and then one day we could open up a
coffee shop and to me you know it wasn't
about it wasn't about anything else than
reclaiming my time and in order for me
to to get to live a meaningful life like
I needed to have my time back I had no
time to live a meaningful life so there
wasn't like this exact defining moment
but I will say that when I when I found
out about minimalism through Josh I mean
I didn't quit like the next month I mean
it took me a year and a half almost two
years to come up with a plan and to work
that plan and to really be disciplined
to get to a point where when I got laid
off I you know I had six months of
savings saved up I wasn't that free but
I paid off a lot of my credit cards I
will say like as soon as I got laid off
like I sold the car that I had and paid
it off and then I went got a car with no
car payment which helped out a lot too
and then got rid of my condo so not one
defining moment but but I do think that
anyone out there you know who is wanting
to leave their job it's certainly
possible with the help of minimalism but
it's not gonna happen overnight right
thank you
thanks for the question howdy what's
your name my name is Caitlin we are to
Halifax is one of my favorite cities are
really disappointing great lobster we
couldn't make it there this year because
of some scheduling stuff but we we
really tried there in Saskatoon we miss
ask a tune this time too so I actually
had a question about values so I
listened to your guys's podcasts and
like I've read your blog posts and have
like used it to kind of sort through
what my foundational values are and I'm
wondering if you can give some advice
when your values conflict and I'll kind
of like elaborate on that where I've
moved to Toronto to like kind of explore
and grow which is one of my foundational
values is growth and explore explore
but then another foundational value is
relationships and like all my family are
back home and because I'm doing so much
here it's like you know you're trying to
call them and it's just kind of like
hard to balance it so I'm wondering if
you guys could shed some insight on that
certainly in fact here's what I'll say I
think most of the time we're gonna
necessarily have contradictory values
and and that sounds weird to even hear
it first but I think that's that's what
makes life exciting and I'll give you
some examples like for me one you might
say relationship so you could say to
love right
you gonna say connection to other people
right but then also I value a loan time
wait a minute wait how can I value a
loan time and and also value connection
or how can I value being significant
like that that is the that is also the
opposite of connection right if I want
to be significant that means that I mean
look I'm on a stage right now talking in
front of a thousand people but but also
I want to be able to connect with people
and so what I'll say is just because
they're mutually exclusive in the moment
doesn't mean that they don't have a
place in your life and so you you moved
away recently so you're away from from
friends and family and that's okay you
can have connection with someone without
being in the in their presence 24 hours
a day obviously and it really has to do
with prioritizing what is most important
important for now and also realizing
that those priorities will change over
time just like our values change over
time the things that we enjoy change
over time just before I was I was coming
in here I went over to Tim Hortons
so I'm from Dayton Ohio and we have Tim
Hortons there and and I used to so I
used to work in Telecom and the guys and
gals from blackberry from rim would
always come down to Dayton and we were
also in Cincinnati but they didn't like
going to Cincinnati because there was no
Tim Hortons there and I used to really
love Tim Hortons but it doesn't seem to
add the same value to my life anymore I
went there today and I sort of felt a
certain nostalgia but I didn't feel that
like oh this is as good as I remembered
it was dude you're in Canada you love
Tim Hortons but here's the truth that
that doesn't say anything about Tim
Hortons it says something about me right
it says that my preferences have changed
and I have changed over time and so also
keep that in mind that you're what you
value today I don't think your values
are gonna change radically but I think
your allocations will change over time
I've noticed I can tell you this since
I'm 36 years old now and the difference
between 10 years ago at age 26 I was
much more about we me and now I'm a lot
more about we and I find that that has
shifted over time it didn't happen
overnight where I'm like all of a sudden
now I feel like I'm just doing nothing
about contributing no it's a slow
progression over this last decade or so
and I think it'll continue to shift yeah
I think it's important that you're
realizing this about yourself too
because I go through the same thing
where like relationships are very very
important to me but I live in Montana
and my family lives in Ohio in upstate
New York
so you know for me it's it's not that I
have to see them every single day or
every single week but I do try to see my
mom a few times a year my dad a few
times a year luckily like they both live
in the in the same the same general area
but you know at the end of the day what
happens if you could like look at your
your values as like buckets and each
bucket has its own value and you know
you can imagine like water in there or
sand in there whatever it is
whenever I get to a point where I'm
feeling a bit of discontent we're like
just something isn't right and I'm
feeling anxious
you know whatever that feeling is that
is because those feelings are triggers
like those are that's your body is your
brain saying hey something's not right
you need to figure this out I will look
at those those buckets and I will see I
will you know kind of see which one is
the least fool and really when it comes
down to it I am as happy or fulfilled
maybe as the least full bucket does that
make sense yeah so so it's it's very
good it's very awesome it you're aware
of that I mean if you are stressing out
about you know keeping those tight
relationships with family back in
Halifax then you know call them more
it's funny I never I didn't call my mom
a lot but I would go see her especially
after I got laid off I go see her you
know once a week or you know once a
really week but now like I will talk to
her on a very regular basis to maintain
that connection my grandmother I hardly
ever saw her like just like holidays and
stuff and yeah just hardly ever but now
like I go out of my way to like call her
and keep that connection going so yeah I
would say I would totally view the Josh
like the the values that we have there
always being of conflict a little bit I
think it's about finding that balance
and and that's really what kind of for
me like helps me live a meaningful life
appreciate it
but by the way real quick if you're
looking to figure out what your values
are my partner Rebecca she has a great
website called minimal wellness and she
put up this her and I we go over our
values together quarterly I think it's
important to just sit down and sort of
talk about like what your values are and
how they're changing and I know you're
laughing at that but it's but it's a
pretty [ __ ] awesome relation love
Josh loves spreadsheets
there's no spreadsheet but she she put
together this sheet that she that she
uses to sort of like figure out like
what is important in my life and how to
identify that so you can find it uh
minimal wellness.com slash values
howdy what's your name hi my name is
Katherine I live here in Toronto and my
question is so about ten days from now
I'm going on a week-long trip and I'm
starting to think about what I need to
bring and okay do I need you know
something for if we go somewhere nice
and something for touristing around all
day and the more I think like this the
more I know that I'm going to end up
with an overstuffed suitcase
so you guys are on the road a lot and I
went wondering if you have any
minimalist packing tips for me indeed
yes so it's interesting because I'll
pack the same thing for a week that I
will a year and I so Ryan and I in 2014
we went out on this crazy hundred city
tour and it was ten months of our lives
basically and it all fit into one
relatively small bag and there was this
bag it's been the bane of my existence
the last few years because we it was in
the documentary that we put out and so a
lot of people are very complimentary
about the documentary but the number one
comment I got was hey where's your bag
from I want to buy that bag
and at first it like I was allergic to
it I'm like that's the only message that
God is I have a nice bag we have failed
you I'm so sorry I'm blowing the
Kickstarter but the truth is that I I
probably get more value from that bag
than any other one physical possession
now if it were to break tomorrow I'd
find a different bag and it'd be okay
it's just it's just a bag but the guy
who makes it he stopped making it in
2012 and he came to us right after the
documentary and I said I'm getting
people were coming to me asking about
this I can't imagine how many people
you're getting would you be interested
in helping me bring this bag back out
and we said no we don't put our name on
any physical item how ironic with that
beam and then a few months later he
wrote us this really big check now I'm
just kidding he did wait a minute
no actually a few months later he just
kept we kept talking about it and I got
to thinking about it is the one thing
that if it does break I won't be able to
replace it so selfishly maybe we should
help him out no the truth is that we
want to find a way to to bring this back
out and so it's actually the first
product we're ever putting our name on
but I fill that bag the same way I would
for a year that I did this week while
while we're traveling and here's the
thing fine a suitcase a bag something
that is appropriately sized for you
because what I used to do is I had an
overstuffed large suitcase and if you
have the space you tend to fill it with
what just in case items I need that
third pair of swimming trunks I need
three extra pairs of underwear I need to
pack a suit with me in case there's an
impromptu funeral
III need all of these just in case items
and what Ryan and I came up with is
something we call the 20/20 rule if if
if you need something if you truly need
it you can purchase it less than $20
less than 20 minutes now first that
sounds like a rule of privilege I don't
want to go around spending 20 40 bucks
every single day on stuff I need just
the case between the two of us we've had
to use that rule five times in the last
six years because the truth is all those
things we thought we were going to need
just in case we're not actually going to
need at all that's my pithy answer nice
and by the way the yeah I'll talk about
it later go ahead you can keep going
I'm still trying to like think of a
tweetable answer no I
yeah the Justin case stuff is definitely
a killer I'll tell you for me I'm gonna
ramble here until I come up with
something so be carries your bag wisely
so I have when I travel I hate to carry
ons I will not do carry ons unless I
absolutely have to you don't I'm sorry
checked bags yeah that's my man I don't
know what I'd do without you man I hate
checking bags like I refuse to have any
check bags that's what I meant to say so
I have only carry-on bags and what I
have is a bag that fits perfectly in the
overhead and then a smaller one like my
laptop bag that will fit underneath the
seat like but for this like for this leg
of four this wave of the tour
I just brought one bag because I can
also put my laptop in there and we're
only gone for like five days so I can
actually just carry that one bag with me
and put it in the overhead I totally
agree with Josh like the packing for one
week at a time like that is a lifesaver
it is absolutely why now I don't have a
garment bag and a duffle bag and a
second duffle bag and a roller bag it's
it is it's very easy to get carried away
it's funny because like when we when we
when Josh first introduced minimalism to
me he sent me a video from Colin right
and when I saw what he was doing it made
sense to me I was like oh yeah okay
minimalism helps him travel the world
well I was like I kind of like owning a
kitchen table like I don't want to have
to I don't want to have to like not own
a kitchen table like and you know
obviously he doesn't cuz he can't carry
that with him on an airplane um but uh
but yeah I really I really did admire
how he was able to kind of carry
everything that he owned with him again
like I didn't want to be a peripatetic
writer but it's something I definitely
could admire really thought some people
come to my mind by now but it hasn't um
I guess I'll just I'll just say this if
I have had to condense all that in 140
characters I would say if you pack for
more than a week when you go on vacation
you're gonna be distracting yourself
from an awesome vacation thank you thank
you hi my name is Marcela
I'm from LinkedIn Ontario got it Wow
there's like five hundred people who
live there they're all here
thanks for bringing them yeah I'm
originally from Chile so I my question
is also about more like geared towards
kids what are your thoughts on things
like social media platforms like
snapchat and Instagram and how they add
value to our lives or if they add value
to our lives particularly when it comes
to younger kids like tweens or my son's
10 so he's just getting he also wants to
own a tiny house but he wants like to be
on every social media platform and I
think that's a good idea but I was just
wondering what your thoughts were in
that I it's a good question I just had I
just had 140 characters come to my mind
[ __ ] I lost it give me a second instead
of being a tool use social media as a
tool yeah I think I think we can easily
trick ourselves and and we can get
distracted by things that we pretend add
value to our lives
I call them imaginary values and
sometimes things that add value today
will turn into an imaginary value
tomorrow if I keep at it right and so
one of the reasons that we have Jess on
the road with us is she helps out with a
lot of social media stuff so that we can
focus on what the task at hand what's
most important to us the social media
and getting the word out and sharing
this is important it's not the most
important thing to us it would distract
us and so my pithy answer has something
to do with distractions I'm gonna I'm
gonna reward mine real quick go for it
so you can think about it what I should
have said was and instead of being a
tool on social media
use social media as a tool yeah that's
much better just write that down
[Applause]
composing yeah so so actually let me let
me ramble on a bit more I think that
that when I look at I look at social
media in teens I also see a bit of an
epidemic what's going on right now
right and I think I in fact I feel kind
of like this this curmudgeonly old man
where where the where the culture is
passing me by and even though I'm still
involved in it to some extent I
understand less and less day by day as
it drifts away from me and rarely did a
distracted person ever create anything
meaningful thank you thank you
okay before we move on I'm gonna try
something new right now you all you you
can you can come over to the mic so we
just started doing this thing called
patreon where we have a certain number
of patreon supporters because we refuse
to do pot advertisements on our podcast
because advertisements suck and so we're
gonna do a quick bonus segment for the
folks who are the thousand people were
here in the theater plus the thousand
people who are listening at home who are
a patreon supporter over at patreon.com
slash the minimalist so we'll do a quick
bonus segment answer at least a couple
questions here for them alright we're
back to the regular podcast that was an
awesome overtime episode thank you all
for participating by the way Ryan I was
thinking as she was talking about
getting rid of the the toys in the
basement I was at the park the other day
with Ella and she had this little troll
doll that she carries around with her
sometimes and she was at the park and we
were playing and there's like these
sprinklers and stuff that I was not
dressed for it so I just got really wet
and as we were playing there she ripped
the trolls head off she decapitated the
troll and then so I she was doing trying
to get me to hold the thing like can you
hold this for me because it's broken and
so the thing I had to explain to her I
said that you know there are three
things you can do with that right now
with the thing that you can't use
anymore and I had to explain to me what
those three things were you could either
donate it to someone right which we
can't do with this and I asked her why
we couldn't donate it and so walking
through the whole process of explain why
you can't donate it you could fix the
thing right this thing was broken beyond
repair and then there's a third option
and I asked her what the third of the
final option is and she said we'll throw
it away and I said okay well we can't
have the first two options so what is
our option right she goes well we have
to throw it away but I don't want to
throw it away today
I want to throw it away tomorrow and I'm
like oh she's not getting it back she
came out to me half an hour later and
she said Joshy
she calls me Joshy she said Joshy is it
tomorrow yet and I guess the moral of
the story is sometimes not everyone's on
the same timeline that we're on and
that's okay and sometimes we have to
wait for them to to catch up all right
let's let's quickly move on to our
added-value portion of the shows where
we each talk about something that has
added value to our lives recently since
we're here in Toronto Canada
Ryan is there something local that has
added value to your life
yeah the Tim Hortons I love Tim Hortons
give me a dozen doughnuts right now I
will destroy them man you know you know
I love about Toronto is that there are
so many local mom-and-pop like
restaurants it's there there are chains
but it's not like the state's it's it's
not like you know there's an Applebee's
and the TGI Fridays in every single
corner so I could list a ton of like
great local places but I'm there's just
one that really stands out to me it's
called hole in the wall and it took and
it's over on Dundas am I saying that
right
Dundas
[Laughter]
yes don't bad straight um so yeah that
if you have if you haven't even there
you heard some people like because the
place is it's amazing that I actually
haven't made a there this trip I was
I visited that place the last time we
were in Toronto um but uh they had like
this one site you love it or hate it but
like there's like this liver pate which
is freakin awesome I love anyone
that's my value-added for a second when
you're trying to pronounce the street
name I thought you're gonna break out
your Canadian accent I tend not to I
tend not to mock my audience he sounds
Eastern you rush like Russian or Eastern
European when he does it yeah it always
comes out the wrong accent anyway
actually every accent he does just
sounds Eastern European we had brunch
today at a place called expectation oh
my god so we're on this really strange
diet I have mercury poisoning which is
really fun like really really really bad
mercury poison so I have this I'm gonna
ketogenic diet right now so all I can
eat yeah all I can eat is like fatty
things and which sounds really good and
so you do that for 2,900 calories a day
and but this place was awesome and I
felt like I was having a treat for the
first time in like two and a half weeks
so thank you Canada
yeah it's awesome yeah that's over in
Trinity Square and then there's a place
the Burke something right there like
right outside the door to the left
anyway what is it the Edmund Burke right
oh the Edmund Burke yes thank you so I
just want to throw one more in there cuz
that place is that was one of the best
burgers I've ever had it's so good
alright let's move on the right here
right now so we talked about what's
going on the lives of the minimalist we
are in the middle of a crazy 40 city
tour right now if you listen to this at
home we're in Toronto right now but
we've got a bunch of other stops in
North America we're also gonna be
hitting Australia really soon those
dates might already be on our website
you must go to les is
Oh calm find all the tour dates theaters
and all that fun stuff a bunch of them
have sold out pretty quickly this place
may have sold out on the last day I'm
not really sure that actually we sold
out a long time ago we had the little
tiny theater so for those of you who
bought tickets first thank you because
you helped us get this bigger theater
thank you
and and then you and then they opened up
the balcony eventually as well so thank
you all for that it's amazing what's
that Ryan I know yes I got it
Ryan says don't forget to mention the
books so if you leave here tonight you
want to purchase one thing no uh
wherever jess is jessica will be out
there afterward and eventually about 20
minutes or so will come out will sign
books take photos dish out hugs sadly we
won't be able to answer questions in
line but we would love to grab a hug
from you all if you don't if you didn't
bring money for a book though let us buy
you one we'd be happy to buy one have
one on us please just please pass it on
when you're done minimize it otherwise
it'll just sit on a shelf and collect us
I mentioned that bag that we were doing
I might as well at least talk about all
quick I wrote an essay called keep
travel simple so that is the first bag
we first product we ever decided to put
our name on and you can find that essay
it's at packed bags calm takt it's the
name of the company that he started just
to bring this bag back out from from the
documentary here's my caveat with that
though most of you probably don't need a
new bag and so don't buy it
but if you decide at some point that you
do need a new bag and you think it's the
right one for you then really think hard
about it and maybe still don't buy it
but it's a really good way here's
Malcolm produces five thousands of these
and no one buys one I will have bags for
several lives which is awesome you can
become a bag hoarder
I don't hoard anything except these five
pounds of travel bags alright we're on
tour we already talked about Houston oh
we talked a little bit on patreon if you
want it we're doing a bunch of we do it
it's pretty much doing a weekly now
private podcasts on just for our patreon
subscribers so help keep our podcasts
100% advertisement free none of the
money zero dollars goes to me or to Ryan
it's going all to build a podcast and
film studio in Los Angeles so we can
create more meaningful creations reach
more people with those creations but
it's certainly not going to our bank
accounts if you're interested in that
just go to the minimalists com click on
donate and you can contribute on a per
episode basis or you contribute just a
one-time on PayPal as well but if you
want to get free live streams and free
bonus or private podcasts you can do
that over on patreon and
oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh
last but not least I want to thank some
folks the man behind the minimalism is
here tonight he's hiding in the shadows
as always he is our tour manager our
operations manager our podcast producer
our book editor and an all-around
outstanding human being ladies and
gentlemen podcast Shawn is somewhere in
the back
and let's give it up one more time for
the Danforth yeah amazing venue amazing
staff you guys are awesome thank you so
much last but not least I want to thank
you you paid some money to be here
tonight and that's really great because
it allows us to pay for a venue allows
us to pay Sean and Jess and security and
all the staff here also travel here but
you also gave up your two most precious
resources tonight your time and your
attention and we're just so grateful for
that you decide to spend some time with
us so if you leave here tonight with
just one message we hope it's this love
people and use things because the
opposite never works
thanks for being here thanks so much
thank you
thank you
[Applause]
hi this is Stephanie from Maine
I started minimizing earlier this year
when I was pregnant my son is now six
months old after much deliberation I
decided to start a small memory box for
him as I have enjoyed having some items
for my childhood growing up and this may
add value to his life at some point I
will save a few items such as his
hospital bracelet birth announcement and
a baby outfit as he gets older he can
decide if he wants to contribute any
items to his box but any saved items
have to fit in the bin the important
thing is that I don't attach sentiment
to these items and project my own
emotions on my son he will decide what
adds value when he is an adult you can
choose to keep some all or no items I
will allow him to make this choice with
no guilt or expectations on my part hi
my name is Morgan I'm from Milwaukee
Wisconsin
I'm calling regards to someone who was
asked about their camping gear and
having all that stuff likes in their
house and why to minimize it one option
and that mission have been long D is the
urban ecology Center it's a non-profit
and this group you donate thirty-five
dollars a year as a single person and it
really just goes towards keeping the
nonprofit going they try and get
community involvement and education
around on the environment and preserve
the wildlife is in the long beach but
the awesome thing about them is that
they offer free camping gear and kayaks
and Mike's like anything that you want
to rent you can ride for up to three
days or longer if you get emotional
requests I'm sure they're not the only
city that there's an option like this
out there so just let me - keep in mind
that there might even like community
groups in the area that help you have
access to those items but not have to
have them in your own home
hello my name is Tom and I live in
Portland Oregon so my comment is about
your last podcast about relocating so a
little over two years ago I moved across
country from Rhode Island's Portland
Oregon and there was probably the most
difficult decision I've ever made I
always had this gut feeling for change
like you bring up in the podcast the
part that really made it hard was that
my mom was in the late stages of ALS and
I was there for her throughout it we
talked a lot about me and moving and she
encouraged me a lot so I decided to do
it and I was very thankful to have a
strong supporting network of friends and
family that also encouraged me at the
time so they when it came the same day I
left I made it to Pennsylvania when my
brother called me and told me my mom had
heart attack and she died so I drove
home the same day
barely stopping and arrived in the
middle of the night to see her empty
bedroom it was devastating I was
nominals broken it was I just spent the
whole night in my bed crying eventually
after warning for a while
Tigger's over a month I made a decision
to continue my trip but I still felt
like I needed that and I knew that she
would want me to keep to honor that
decision it was hard it was very
difficult but there's probably one of
the best decisions I've ever made is one
of the most enlightening trips road
trips I've ever experienced I was by
myself I just went straight across
States
taking everything I saw is through the
great experience
so now I start getting that feel like
that feeling again for change and then I
encourage everybody that I meet the
challenge themselves would change and
grow
life is flux and go out there and do
your best to be the best you
[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed oh I bet that you'll
be fine without
[Music]
every little thing that you gotta have
every little thing that you got you
gotta reach for you gotta grab oh I bet
that you'll be fine
without your team
[Music]
you
[Music]